je quitte sachant que les choses sont
entre bonnes mains steven guilbeault kit
équiterre l'organisme qu'il a cofondé
avec sidney ribaux il y avait 25 ans
comparaissait pour des extraterrestres
en outre étaient même de melon d'eau
vous savez on était vert à l'extérieur
et rouges à l'intérieur nous étions des
communistes déguisé en écolo oui on
apportait avec nous un camion solaire
bien des choses ont changé depuis la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
est devenue une affaire sérieuse mais il
a fallu des manifestations et des coups
d'éclat pour faire prendre conscience à
la population de l'urgence d'agir comme
ici en 2001 ou steven guilbeault qui a
rejoint greenpeace escalade la tour du
cn à toronto les états unis d'amérique
sont toujours pris en otage par de leur
bd combustibles fossiles dans ces grands
écologiste de la première heure il
participe ensuite à toutes les
rencontres mondiales sur le climat
kyoto japon buenos aires est sous brésil
et la conférence de paris sur le climat
au sommet du g8 en 2002 on le voit
préparer des fripes à l'énergie solaire
le port
pour la future élite biologique à
montréal en 2005 ils manifestent lors de
la conférence sur les changements
climatiques
il est de toutes les batailles la
dernière en lice le pipeline d'énergie
est entre temps il a changé de look
rasé de près costume cravate on le voit
souvent en compagnie de politiciens ce
qui déplaît aux écologistes purs et durs
qui le trouvent trop près du pouvoir
on lui prête d'ailleurs des intentions
politiques il ne ferme pas la porte
est ce que je vais faire de la politique
à court terme non est ce qu'un jour je
ferai de la politique peut-être
l'élection et dans presque un an est ce
que je pourrai décider de faire le show
peut-être mais comme il le dit lui même
il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire
il sera peut être tenté de le faire
autrement ici catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal